Well, it's Ramadan, and that always,
always, always means that some followers
of a certain false prophet are going to
become more violent. People in the West
keep making the mistake of seeing
Ramadan through a nice Christian lens.
They think, "Oh, if this is a holy month
for them, they're going to become more
peaceful because they're focusing on
God."
Not if your God commands you to
violently subjugate the world.
Focusing more on a God who commands you
to violently subjugate the world is
going to make you more
what? Peaceful?
Seriously?
The Dawah Bros are no exception to this
rule. So, not surprisingly, they're
dialing up the threats. One of them just
sent God Logic a message threatening to
make his wife a widow and his children
orphans.
That's right. I'm talking about the
Warner, a big dumb dawah dork who's
friends with Sneako, Sheikh Uthman,
Mohammed Hijab, Ali Dawah, and so on.
This giant loser spends his Ramadans
riding the loser coaster at Loser Land
on Losers Get In Free Day.
I'm going to give you some background on
Warner so you can see how massively
dysfunctional dawah is, and then we'll
read a Ramadan threat this epic coward
just sent to God Logic. So, who is the
Warner?
Well, we don't have to wonder because at
the end of last year, one of his
friends, a Muslim named Malik, who
happens to be the biggest snitch in
history, finally got fed up and exposed
what we might call
dawah after dark.
Hey chat, who who wants to know about
the real Warner? Oh, we do.
Chat, you want to see who Warner really
is?
The Warner is probably the fakest of
them all. Like between Libyano Central,
all them, Warner's Warner in terms of
the Islamic stuff, fakest of them all.
Fakest of them all.
Malik even addresses the Warner directly
about what he was willing to do to get
into the Illuminati.
You literally begging to be in the
Illuminati, bro. Asking me how do you
get in like I'm in it. You're the one
who literally said in front of me and
other people that you take it up the
butt as long as it it got you into the
game where you could make an influence.
Wallahi he said that in front of people.
So, the Warner wanted to enter the
Illuminati by letting the Illuminati
enter him.
Can't say it's not Sunnah though. We all
know about Muhammad on the night of Al
Zutt.
But what does the Warner do with his
Dawah donations?
This guy is the biggest pothead on this
planet, bro. The guy you you take Dawah
from, all he does is roll one up. That's
all he does.
Chat, this guy gets high as hell all day
and all night. Well, so Wallahi may
Allah curse me. This guy goes high to
the mosque. This guy literally goes to
give Dawah high high every day or every
weekend, sorry. If he if he's going to
the dispensary with the money he's
getting for the Qurans, chat. Guys, I
gave this guy money.
I gave this guy money for Quran. He went
to the dispensary and spent my money
instead. So, he spends Dawah donations
on weed.
But you know what else costs money?
Mut'ah.
By the way, guys, you know Warner's been
married nine times?
Warner's been married nine times. Nine.
Nine times, chat.
Mut'ah. This guy's a mut'ah This guy
went on vacation with a Moroccan girl,
married her for five minutes, and then
and then divorced her on the way home.
If I'm lying, I'm dying.
Mut'ah is a form of prostitution. You
pay the girl to marry you for a day or
for an hour or in the Warner's case for
5 minutes.
But that's apparently what he does when
he wants to have sex with a Muslim girl.
With non-Muslim girls, he just
in his words, "smashes them."
Brother, this guy's smashing girls every
weekend.
Malik, I just smashed this chick. I'm
like, "Bro, why are you even doing that?
Why do you Why don't you fall in love
with a a proper girl and get married?"
Nah, bro, I'm smashing. I'm smashing
every weekend. Warner called me while he
was in Miami and he had a chick. He was
on FaceTime. He had a chick in his bed.
This guy had a chick in his bed calling
me on FaceTime.
A random girl that he picked up.
Let's keep going. You want me to keep
going? You can keep going, Malik.
But can you please snitch on some of the
other Dawah Bros as well?
Hey chat, how who knows about Warner and
Adam Saleh having threesomes? You want
me to start name-dropping your whole
life? You and Adam, you telling me about
you and Adam doing threesomes together
on Dawah trips? I'm talking about bro
who people who literally go to the clubs
at nights and hand out Qurans during the
day. What the hell is that? It's Dawah.
And apparently, the Dawah Bros have
pretty open minds when it comes to trans
women.
These guys, bro, we're in the club with
with t t monsters. And Warner's like,
"Oh, I didn't know that." But he knew it
the whole time. He's like, "No, I did
know actually." But he's like, "I don't
care." Bro, these guys, bro, all fake.
Bro, Adam and all them, bro, all fake at
the club
with with with he-shes and then going to
Debate Logic and getting baked.
Rub-a-dubbing in the club with who knows
how many letters of the LGBTQIA+
community.
The Dawah Bros even run trains on girls
or perhaps on people who just look like
girls.
Bro, he helps Nico do do all his crap,
bro. You do run trains in rooms
together. Adam and Slim and Sneako all
run trains in rooms together with Warner
there. And they do this on Dawah trips?
Chat, what were they doing in Columbia?
What did him and Sneako do in Columbia?
And Myron? Guys, these guys were
smashing birds in Columbia.
Bro, wallahi, may Allah curse me if I'm
lying. I got I got the receipt right
here.
Brother, I have receipts of him and
Muslim Lantern and Sneako and and Bosnia
and [__] What are you on about? So,
that's the Warner. He spends Dawah
donations on drugs and mut'ah wives. He
does three-ways with his Dawah bros,
runs trains with his Dawah bros, hits
the club with trans women, and
volunteers to take it up the butt.
So, if you need someone to take one for
the team, the Warner is your guy.
And his followers don't care even
slightly about any of this.
As long as you post videos of yourself
handing out Qurans or preaching Islam at
the park, they don't care what you do
afterwards.
They love the Warner especially because
he posts videos where he thugs out on
people. Yeah, cuz I called my dog
Muhammad once and he gave me like a
warning. What did you say?
What did you say? Are you serious? I'm
sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I didn't
know. I didn't know. I didn't know. Get
out of here, bro.
We were in Times Square last week for
the Ramadan prayer pageant and zoot
memorial extravaganza.
And Muslims were praising the Warner for
his powerful Dawah.
So, listen up.
Right now, I know there's a lot of
brothers over there. Shout out to my
brother the Warner right over there
giving Dawah. Yo, make some noise for
the brother Warner right NOW, BABY.
OH, DON'T SCARE THEM, BROTHERS. RELAX.
But they were really praising him for
thugging out. Anthony shouted, "Jesus is
Lord." And the Warner tried to
intimidate him.
Didn't work.
Then he tried to intimidate Drake.
THAT DIDN'T WORK, EITHER.
WHAT ARE YOU WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO TELL
THEM?
JESUS IS LORD.
IT'S NOT YET. RELAX. SIT DOWN. HEY, ARE
YOU that intimidated?
Yo, are you that intimidated?
ARE YOU THAT INTIMIDATED? YOU GOT TO SAY
SOMETHING?
WHAT YOU DOING?
WHY DID YOU STEP UP LIKE THAT?
YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING?
WHAT ARE YOU GETTING ALL FRISKY FOR?
YEAH, DON'T STEP UP TO ME LIKE THAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET HURT.
DON'T STEP UP TO ME LIKE YOU ARE GOING
TO GET HURT.
>> [laughter]
>> DRAKE STARED HIM DOWN. AND THE WARNER,
right in front of police, did the
finger across the throat sign.
Then, after running his finger across
his throat, he complained to police like
a little coward.
This is very upsetting. This is very
upsetting. This is very upsetting. I I
understand, but we're here to help you
guys out. I appreciate that. Danny ran
his mouth about how he was about to hurt
someone. Things started to get ready to
Almost lost my cool right now, man.
Almost knocked the dude out, man.
Hey, bro. You have no idea, bro. I was
about to go Hulk smash, bro. I was about
to go Hulk smash, bro. You feel me?
Danny went and hid beside Sneako, his
partner in smashing hoes on Dawah trips.
He was lined up for prayer, but he was
way more concerned about one of the
cameramen stepping in front of his
camera than he was about praying.
Texting was also more important than the
prayer.
>> [singing]
[singing]
>> So, we can see why Malik said that he's
a total fake.
Warner's Warner in terms of the Islamic
stuff, fakest of them all.
We went through some of the footage on
Giant DOC's channel.
Big tough Warner soon showed up in the
comments and threatened to sue us for
defamation and slander. He said,
"I'm going to sue you for defamation and
slander for purposely spreading lying
about me. You are completely aware
admitted to slandering me on purpose.
He's a compulsive liar and yet you keep
replaying the lies for clicks and
attention. I'm looking forward to suing
you for everything you got. I'm coming
for every one of you guys spreading lies
about me. All the evidence I need are on
your YouTube channels. It's an open and
shut case. See you in court.
Good luck with that, Warner. I think
you'll have better luck with your
Illuminati initiation.
I agree with you that Maleek is a
compulsive liar, but he's got the
receipts for everything he said about
you.
You can still sue, but you might want to
ask your pal Muhammad Hijab how these
lawsuits turn out.
But now we get to God Logic. God Logic
replied to the Warner's threat to sue.
He said,
"Sheesh.
Dawah is all about talking tough and
acting big, then calling the cops and
crying about the little mean
Christians." Laughing emojis. "Warner,
you're a weak clown like the rest. Your
boy Maleek exposed you. He let us all
know what you're really into. Don't try
and act like his narration wasn't
sahih." More laughing emojis.
And that's when the Warner sent a
Ramadan threat to God Logic. He wrote,
"You were such a good little boy the
first time we met. I had no idea who you
were and I allowed you to speak to me.
You hid all your hate for Islam in front
of me that day like the little coward
you are knowing what would happen to you
if you expressed that same hate face to
face. Then suddenly behind a computer
screen you switch up and now you want to
act tough. I'll make you eat your words.
You better have the same energy when we
meet face-to-face.
Also, I'm not afraid of death. I hope
you're not afraid of death either or
leaving your wife as a widow and your
children as orphans.
So, just a few days after giving Drake
the finger across the throat sign right
in front of Zubair al-Mawlawi Donnie's
NYPD, the Warner tells God logic that he
hopes he's not afraid of leaving his
wife as a widow and his children as
orphans.
Will this bother his fans at all?
Absolutely not.
Will it bother his fellow Dawahgandists,
Sneako, Shakeel Ahmad, Muhammad Hijab,
Ali Dawah, and so on?
Not a bit.
This is the state of Dawah in 2026.
You can use Dawah donations to buy weed,
practice mut'ah, have three-ways with
your Dawah bros, run trains on girls,
party with trans women, volunteer to
take it up the butt, and threaten
popular Christians. And Dawah fans will
have zero problem with any of it as long
as you post your little video clips
handing out Qurans at the park.
Dawah is a complete joke.
And it's only going to get worse.
Going to be a fun year though
if you like to watch total meltdowns.
To you Muslims who are watching, let me
ask.
Are we supposed to be impressed by this?
Do you expect us to look at all this
repulsive, dysfunctional, idiotic,
caveman lunacy and conclude that Islam
must be the truth?
Or should this be yet another sign that
Muhammad was a false prophet who brought
nothing but a bunch of demonic
antichrist nonsense.
You lied on that.
He just [__] finally.
He just [__] [music] finally. This is
a power of religion. There's a reason to
it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?